[Musik]
darüber müssen wir sprechen mit matthias
quendt direktor vom institut für
demokratie und zivilgesellschaft einen
schönen guten tag nach jena her kennt am
ende sprach innenminister horst seehofer
über den linksextremismus er sagt eine
stetig sinkende hemmschwelle sei beim
linksextremismus zu beobachten dazu muss
man sagen
insgesamt gibt es weniger links als
rechtsextremistische straftaten aber im
vergleich nehmen die
linksextremistischen straftaten zu woran
liegt das
das kann verschiedene ursachen haben
ursachen sind unter anderem dass die
politischen handlungsfelder die
gesellschaftlichen spaltung linien an
denen sich linke radikalisieren sehr
vielfältig sind von der klimafrage über
die frage von bezahlbarem wohnraum und
natürlich die auseinandersetzung mit
rechtsextremismus der in den vergangenen
jahren erstrahlt das bis in den
rechtsterrorismus das kannten teil des
milieus zu der wahrnehmung führen dass
der staat nicht genug macht oder dass
auch meldungen etwa über
rechtsextremismus in der polizei dazu
führen dass man den staat nicht mehr nur
nicht vertraut oder ihn sogar als frei
und als gegner betrachtet das drückt
sich dann unter anderem aus den zahlen
die zeigen dass er vor allem auch
angriffe auf die polizei
außer diesem aus linken motiven nach den
statistiken des bundeskriminalamtes zu
100 machen jetzt kennen wir die zahlen
des verfassungsschutzberichtes aus dem
jahr 2020 noch nicht aber es ist
wahrscheinlich anzunehmen dass insgesamt
eine zunahme von rechts als auch
linksextremistische straftaten zu
erwarten ist was sind die ursachen dafür
aus ihrer sicht naja also zunächst die
zahlen ja bekannt weil das dieselben
zahlen sind die die bunte die polizei
vor stellt ja es sind ja die zahlen des
bundeskriminalamts die hier noch mal
vorgestellt werden die sind seit vier
wochen bekannt der verfassungsschutz hat
noch andere zahlt über mitglieder
angaben usw
aber wenn wir mal über den
und gewalttaten bleiben dann muss man
schon sagen dass in hinblick auf
zumindest die gewalttaten
es war ein anstieg gegenüber dem vorjahr
gibt in allen bereichen der auch
durchaus kurs ist allerdings war das
jahr 2019 wenn man so will relativ
zivilisiert das bedeutet auch die
gesamtzahl der körperverletzungen der
stadt der gewalttaten ist eigentlich für
die letzten zehn jahre eher
unterdurchschnittlich das bedeutet also
man hat es immer jährlich mit
schwankungen zu tun das hat damit zu tun
dass gibt es für anlässe gibt es wahlen
gibt es größere politische ereignisse
große internationale gipfel und so
weiter insofern muss man sich vor augen
halten dass 2020 ein sehr bewegtes jahr
aber vom anschlag in hanau bis über die
antirassistischen blacklight matters
proteste über querdenken und so weiter
und insofern würde ich insgesamt sagen
ist das eine moderate variabilität die
sich jetzt direkt die sich also in den
vergangenen zehn jahren das ist jetzt
kein besonders großer ausreise sie haben
die querdenken bewegung gerade
angesprochen welche rolle spielt die bei
den zahlen auch darauf wurde er bei der
vorstellung der zahlen des
bundeskriminalamtes schon hingewiesen
dass hier einerseits neue kategorien
entstanden sind in der betrachtung das
heißt also dass fälle von angriffen auf
beispielsweise sicherheitsbehörden oder
auch vertreter auch mandat und
amtsträger zugenommen haben in bereichen
die nicht rechts und links eingeordnet
werden können wir wissen dass der
verfassungsschutz eine neue kategorie
geschaffen hat um diese querdenken
bewegungen zu fassen die bezeichnet wird
als verfassungsschutz gezogene die
legitimierung des staates das ist eine
etwas seltsame kategorie in meinen augen
weil sie auch missbrauchsanfällig ist da
kann man ziemlich viel drunter darunter
fassen wenn man das will
tatsächlich aber wissen wir wir haben
die bilder vor augen von den
der störungen der reichstags treppe im
sommer letzten jahres bis hin zu allen
möglichen versammlungen im ganzen land
bei denen es auch zu
auseinandersetzungen mit polizei und
medien kam es im journalismus nicht
eingegriffen gegendemonstrantinnen
angegriffen das ist aus meinen augen
schon das was im letzten jahr besonders
ist allerdings muss man auch hier sagen
vor dieser historisch besonderen lage
der pandemischen situation von
historischem ausmaß sind auch das
protest ereignisse gewesen
doch insgesamt im rahmen geblieben sind
wenngleich natürlich genau achten muss
wie sich solche verschwörungs
erzählungen bestimmte zuschreibungen
jetzt in den nächsten monaten und jahren
noch weiter entwickeln werden und im
internet sehen wir zumindest da auch
radikalisierung strings genau und um
dieses problem in den griff zu bekommen
muss man wahrscheinlich verstehen wie es
entsteht also wie laufen diese
radikalisierung prozesse ab da kommen
wir extrem wichtigen punkt und
gleichzeitig sehr schwierigen punkt weil
es sicherlich prototypische
radikalisierung stade gibt gleichzeitig
und das betrifft insbesondere auch den
bereich des rechtsextremismus können ist
ganz unterschiedliche hintergründe seien
das haben wir auch bei den anschlägen in
den letzten jahren gesehen
das können personen sein die schon lange
in der neonazi szene aktiv sind das
können menschen sein die noch gar nicht
aufgefallen sind 2015 und 16 hatten wir
die situation dass selbst beamte
anschläge auch asylunterkünfte begangen
haben bis hin zu rentnerinnen die häuser
angezündet haben das heißt also diese
radikalisierungsprozess sind unerforscht
man muss immer einerseits auf die
individuelle ebene gucken man muss
zweitens schauen welche motive welche
rechtfertigung bieten die bewegungen an
und dann auch welche
gesellschaftspolitischen spaltung linien
gibt es an denen sich radikalisierung
vollziehen kann weil das ist aus meiner
sicht ein ganz zentraler fakt den wir
verstehen müssen extremismus
radikalisierung ist nichts was neben der
gesellschaft passiert sondern es kommt
aus der geschichte welche verantwortung
hat die gesellschaft in diesem fall die
gesellschaft hat eine verantwortung
insbesondere auch im bereich von
prävention das heißt verfassungsschutz
und polizei sitzen dann an wenn es ja im
grunde schon
zu spät ist wir erleben aber eine
polarisierung die in den nächsten
monaten vermutlich im zusammenhang mit
den bundestags bereit auch noch zunehmen
wird wir erleben eine polarisierung bis
hin zur farbe zu fake informationen bis
zur desinformation die nicht nur aus den
sogenannten extremistischen milieus
kommt sondern die teilweise es in den
mainstream geschafft hat die zu einer
polarisierung führen und diese
polarisierung kann dazu führen dass
manche eben weiter geht dass sie sich
weiter radikalisieren in telegramm
gruppen oder auch in lokalen in lokalen
bezugsgruppen wo man sich zusammentut
radikalisierung kann passieren im
kontext von ereignissen wie
demonstrationen beispielsweise in
chemnitz 2018 das war ein enormer
radikalisierung beschleuniger für die
extreme rechte radikalisierung kann
passieren in bezug auf den politischen
gegner
da sprechen wir von kumulative
radikalisierung von gegen
radikalisierungen das heißt das spektrum
ist sehr weit und entsprechend weit
aufgestellt sind auch die
gegenstrategien sein
ich sage herzlichen dank matthias quendt
direktor vom institut für demokratie und
zivilgesellschaft dankeschön